hi guys I'm Greg with the lovely and
talented Ashley and Ashley ed nur from
the channel how to use with Morgan and
Ashley we're two hot chicks a brunette
and a blonde she blonde oh she's blonde
that's right I love your Facebook and
Instagram is how to lawns maker brunette
no she's blonde again blonder
that's why you win but she's blonde
still I don't know I should just die her
bird ad it would make a channel more
appealing but then the title wouldn't
make sense all I change the title you
know guess I'm the beginning sage trust
me I know how these how few channels
work thank you I know how to run them
well check them out on YouTube they have
an Instagram of basic you fall Ashley on
her Instagram page as well where it's
very like Christian like photos totally
yeah like when he's like not at the
beach not in a bikini
she's wearing like a priest outfit not a
nun okay everything's covered me I'm
like a blind religion anyway
after those two an actress hey speaking
of acting there's these actors in a
movie because it's a movie so features
actors what clothes transitioning this
fight red band trailer Charlie Day and
Ice Cube I've always wanted to see those
two together that's me a match made in
heaven right white guy white guy that's
all you need for a central comedy fist
fight let's see if we're gonna watch
this movie there's a practical jokes oh
[ __ ] don't have money from books we got
money for this year's uncle all you
gotta do is put in your order and it
done dressed coffee you're gonna drop
that coffee machine off
this is the worst I've ever seen Frank
I'm weird about the field
she's quartering on your giant dick plan
you keep out of control stick to the
standing [ __ ] fatigue it got them to
do the telephone and weirdo
Amy's kids grow up and then one day and
it's just like BAM they're 18 you can
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] on the school all day and don't
nobody do nothing
imma show you what I can't wait to [ __ ]
you up
I'm sorry what we're gonna handle our
differences like real mean what
differences you got a job and not don't
that's the [ __ ] did you challenge mr.
Campbell to recite I'll see you at 3
o'clock usually sighing that people are
like hey I'm going to stop on that guy
oh girl you lose oh not all the threats
out of you [ __ ] just arrest the guy
carry with fine [ __ ] the police
Oh God if they got it all hopped up on
homemade masks not the best batch go
haha sorry how do you know how I know
what use the guidance counselor don't do
maths period when I'm not here you don't
do if I need them all of this [ __ ]
luckily Campbell got a book right back
it
[ __ ] sons of [ __ ] this is
getting balling I was like a [ __ ]
million
[Music]
well ash whoa whoa what did you think
Ashley I mean I was funny I'm a little
confused on the storyline to be on did
you fully understand what wasn't
happening there it's all leading up to a
fistfight yeah [ __ ] off it's fine well
yes I know but like well Charlie day
snitches on Ice Cube about something
right and then I see you gets fired so
he challenges into a fistfight
interesting and then I don't know why
there's all these other wacky [ __ ] going
on in me treat me like a literal like
sin fight happening but no yeah
literally get this one can now I would
be a little positive here all right
and I'm like criticizing a little bit I
see a little positive positive you ready
for this I love Charlie day I like him
too I think Charlie days it's terrible
what was i [ __ ] boy you know I liked
him in horrible horrible bosses yes he's
hysterical and I'm a big fan of it so
it's funny in Philadelphia now I pointed
out in one video that Ashley has done
several acting roles I was in one
episode of It's Always Sunny look cute a
screen shot oh did you work with him to
be leading yeah he was him and the other
guy Mac they were like directing us that
day my one line I was like what is he
like 40 that's nice kid number two you
know did he talk to you in real life at
the high-pitched voices that no I wish
that would have been a much more
interesting story to answer that
question I should have lied IceCube I
think is really good in these comedies
he's because he's like every comedy he's
in he's always tough guy yeah I never
seen a sensitive guy yeah I'd like to
see Ice Cube be a little sensitive kind
of a go against his gangster image a
little bit probably a woman he didn't
use a glistening tear coming down I'm
going I would like him exactly exactly
and it is Jill Julianne Bell is that the
teacher yeah I think she's a teacher
Julianne Bell was the funniest one
trailer yeah she's kind of like a lot of
things recently right to come like a
newcomer I mean I mean how do you is she
I mean okay her age isn't on IMDB marked
position never put their age out there
also never work in Hollywood ever again
right better take a job yeah take your
age off you don't know hundra 37 years
old well she was in workaholics and she
was in 22 Jump Street that's what I
remember her friend yeah she was like
the villain and I think Jillian bells
are really funny actress and I think
she's one of the funnier the South vodka
heavier comedian do you think she's
going to be like the new what's her with
her name from Amy Schumer well no no the
one from the room you don't know nope oh
the the pitch movie yes what that chick
named rebel yes yes yeah I think that
she's gonna be even knew her do you
think so
thanks LT brings a different kind of dry
delivery after like rebeled a little
more out there yeah where she seems a
little bit more tamed a little more
subtle than her hmm maybe for the shine
out I think she's still real I think
she's hilarious
you know hundred resina hendrix yes what
chief is in this trail yes she was a
redhead isn't she from Mad Men
yeah whoa she like lost a lotta weight
this video is all about the weight of
women yeah that's all I notice in a
chicken I'm skinnier fast oh I just oh I
she still looks great yeah she's amazing
I haven't seen her do a comedy but I
know she was just in the new Bad fan of
- ah so now she's doing these like
comedy called said she was in Drive
oh yeah that's on the comedy no but I
thought it was a very yeah yeah the
phone looks okay okay it looks like a
renter to be honest yeah a renter like
I'm gonna rented ladies like like a
rental yeah a renter a renter sound like
someone who Reds me from red box yeah
yeah I could definitely see yeah this is
like on Netflix or Warner Brothers like
sent me the DVD
savvy and then we sent a screening of it
I would watch it what I pay to watch her
movie that's all different story I might
sneak into the theater yeah exactly my
peterhof a little bit
to be part of the movie marathon Liz
yeah the Johson kind of hit-or-miss to
me yeah I don't know I feel like it's
going to be okay it looks like it's
committing to its absurdity it might be
better than what we're speaking you know
rule sometimes I like going to movies
are like my expectations are kind of
lower which is the case here and then
going in in the night that is funnier
than we used to you know especially with
comedies like this that have to seem
like they have so much wackiness going
on and it sometimes you need to see the
scene play out you have just a montage
of a bunch of like well there's a horse
in the [ __ ] hallway now and the paint
all over him and all this there's a dick
carved into the lawn
yes like there's so much going on that
sometimes you need a full team to play
it out that's why I thought my funniest
parts were when they were just like
letting Jillian Bell talk because we
were just watching that scene play out
yeah and Tracy Morgan looks like you do
this Tracy Morgan thing yeah it's funny
funny guy funny guy I think they all
right mommy no no those were more
talented than good yeah all right guys
you're gonna watch the fist fight movie
put your comments I might read them find
out if I do you wanna know maybe I'll
reply maybe I want subscribe to the real
rejects Ashley Edna is the star of the
channel now to the cosine with Morgan
and Ashley now you're these star in my
eyes Tom I just get past all of Morgan's
part Tori's are watching Morgan I want
you to know that I just get past all
your part really I have no interest in
who you this is how you appeal to women
right yeah talking about their weight
how would you organize like I should be
the guest star in your video really show
you how to get women you got to talk
down on them so what does the game I
read the book in the game
you have yes I haven't I've read it I
just wanted to understand how guys
worked yet I wanted to know so when I
saw a doesn't shoot read the game I
never read it maybe you should or maybe
I'm lying
this is a whole new challenge no Morgan
is beautiful I don't see a faster parts
follow her on
jam and how to blondes make a right and
follow her ashley editor yeah remember
when we all used to go to LA Fitness
together that's when you guys first
joined a gym
don't go there I know is with me take
classes with you
I know Body Works yeah love because
Ashley said a huge crush on me that's
the way it was back then obviously she
has a big crush on I did to stop it
clatter yeah it might be much she kept
coming on to me and I was like Ashley
you Dido like refueler not again